and deborah when war comes people flee
and those pictures there we're seeing
now live pictures from here in kiev um
well they tell the very clear story
those people are heading one way and
that is out it's quite extraordinary and
i think both you and i have been struck
um over the last few weeks of reporting
from here about how people have been
very resilient not not wanting to think
that that wall could come and not
wanting to flee i mean some families
they might have sent children to the
west the west seen as it's the border
that ukraine has with the eu uh
bordering with poland and seen as the
safest part of the country shouldn't an
offensive happen which it now is but
today yes this is the first time um
since this crisis started that we're
seeing mass mobilization of people it
would seem it's exactly what western
officials have warned would happen that
not only would a russian invasion of
ukraine inflict huge suffering on this
country but it would also trigger
potentially a major refugee crisis this
is not a good time of year to be on the
road to be without power potentially
without water without food or easy
supply of those essentials and now to
see families packing into their cars and
heading west it would seem uh really
underlines the sense of utter crisis in
this country and even though we've been
warned and us intelligence has been
warning us and the world and they've
been very open about it joe biden's been
very open about it even though
we were warned it is still quite
shocking to see
images
like this in a thriving
european capital city and to hear the
reports of what we're hearing of you
know about what is happening in the rest
of the country it is it's it's so stark
like yesterday we were walking around
the center the center of the city we
were doing some filming and
seeing little boutique shops cafes
people sitting around having their
normal life a normal life that anyone in
western in the western world would be
able to easily recognize to see that
turned on its head so immediately from
night to day here we have a country
that's currently at war is um it's
really really hard to comprehend and
also interesting that the western tactic
of basically revealing exactly what
president putin's game plan was
it hasn't had any effect it's almost
like he doesn't really care um he
doesn't care the fact that no one
believes his false narrative to justify
this invasion
he's just gone ahead with it anyway and
i think this is a fundamental point
actually when you listen to those
western leaders for example at the
munich security conference over the
weekend it sounded great talking about
our values talking about the need to
uphold the rule of law freedom democracy
uh human rights all these values that
we've known and supported since the end
of the second world war saying that this
action by russia would be in defiance of
that and warning of unprecedented
sanctions should vladimir putin act he
doesn't care it's had zero effect and i
think this is a defining moment for our
entire world the balance of power in our
world and the balance of democracies
versus authoritarian regimes and what
this action might mean for other leaders
who don't like the democratic way of
life but if
sanctions
are not going to work they clearly
haven't worked i mean it's underway uh
they have it hasn't worked what else
what else is there if nato
stands by its principle of not
getting involved if it's not a
nato country
then you know putin has seen a
a weakness and gone for it he really has
he's obviously balance he's obviously
calculated that the pain he will suffer
from the west as a result of this action
is worth enduring because of the gain
that he will get
from if he is right in his calculation
and if this is indeed what he plans to
do
taking control of this country and
ensuring wrenching it away from any
desire and ability to be westward
leaning to link him with the eu to link
him with nato that's been his constant
message hasn't it about he sees the idea
of ukraine joining nato as an
existential threat now these pictures
of what we're told of russian troops
um coming across at uh this is
incredible
this will be happening
now this is crimea i'm told but this
will be happening if those reports about
several
regions borders being breached this will
be happening
sort of all around ukraine at this
moment well in december i went up to the
to spend some time with the border guard
up in the northern crossing where
you go into belarus which again belarus
is where russia has masked some 30 000
troops and they would be they are the
troops that um western officials believe
would be used for an assault on on kiev
if they were going to do a ground
assault
and the border guards up there they you
know they they didn't they obviously
were willing and ready to fight if
necessary um but the idea that they
could be able to withstand
a huge mobilization like that i mean
they will obviously try but there would
clearly be casualties and as that report
from the border guard already is saying
this morning they've had three
fatalities already